Uh Ibrahim, if you could come back up
and try to try again. Your connection
failed last time, but uh you can come up
and try again, Ibrahim. There you go.
>> Yeah.
>> Hopefully now better.
>> Okay. Uh just to clarify one thing that
you know like I'm good, you know, my
English is not that very good, but I
will try my best to explain the
situation.
>> Okay.
>> So, uh as you said, you know, the topic
is Islam is false. change my mind.
Basically, you know, I I brought up and
I was grown up as as a Muslim to a
Muslim family. So, I I took the
religion, you know, like out of my
family. But after, you know, like I will
not say, you know, like I seek the
knowledge but I got some information it
was the only religion which is Islam
makes, you know, like more sense for me.
So this is this is this is after I will
not say that I read the Bible and I I
read the Old Testament all of them but
you know like I read some of uh the
verses and it was you know like has
contradiction
on them so that that's make me you know
like stay and stick with my religion not
you know like changing to another
religion.
>> Okay. So, you heard what I was just
sharing with the previous guest, right,
on why I think Islam is false because it
makes certain claims that turn out to be
false. Like, they're just completely
untrue, right? One of those being that
the previous scriptures mention the
Quran. So, if the previous scriptures
don't mention the Quran, then the Quran
is false. It's making a false claim.
>> Yeah. Ba basically I was uh writing for
you in the comment sections that which
uh which uh because you mentioned 26 but
you I I didn't get uh the the number of
the verse.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. It was 196.
196.
>> 26. What?
>> So it's chapter 26 verse
196.
>> 196. I don't know. I have a problem with
the Tik Tok. If I need to go and check
the Quran application, it will, you
know, like the Tik Tok
>> I can show it on the I can show it on
the camera.
>> Yes, please. Yeah, you would. Yeah, you
got you will make a big favor.
>> All right. Teamwork makes the dream
work. Ibrahim. Okay.
>> Exactly. Yes.
>> All right. So, see here. So here's the
verse here and it says and indeed it is
in brackets it says mentioned in the
scriptures of former peoples
>> you know is there any way that you can
bring it in Arabic so
>> yeah yeah yeah
>> cuz you know my first language is Arabic
so
yeah
>> there we go
>> so yeah you know this is a very short ve
so if we need to understand that if we
need to go, you know, like
>> a few verses before, right?
>> Yeah. Before and after, then we can
>> Yeah. We can we can start at verse 192
for uh for context. We'll go to 192 and
then we'll read for forward. Okay. So,
it's uh or
it's a revelation from the Lord.
>> Now, just from my my curiosity, does it
say Quran in the Arabic or No.
>> No. But there is you know which called
which is this
refer to the Quran.
>> Okay. Cool. Cool. Cool.
>> Yeah. Yeah. There is I don't know what's
the name of English but this
it doesn't says Quran but this
refer to the Quran.
>> Gotcha.
>> Okay. Good to know. All right. And so
this verse here 193 next verse.
>> Yeah. mean which is was brought down by
an angel or you know like a re a
revelation you know through
>> yeah the spirit the spirit brought it
down right and then it says this all
right next verse
upon your heart this is he talked to
Muhammad
>> and
that you you know
>> maybe a warner yeah I understand it yes
>> okay good
>> and and in which is in Arabic language.
>> Mhm. Revealed it in the Arabic language
and then 196.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Definitely it talks about
Quran. Yeah.
>> Okay. So, yeah. Go ahead.
>> Yeah. The Quran it's
so yeah it was you know like mentioned
maybe. Yeah. So yeah it could be the
right thing. So my thing is is that
obviously I read the previous
scriptures. Um I read the Torah. I read
the Gospel. I do it every day. And
uh there's nowhere where the Quran is
mentioned in them. Nowhere does the
previous scriptures mention the the
Quran. And so um because the Quran is
making a claim like this, it's
demonstrating like like it gives us this
this is something that that is testable,
right? like we can actually verify this
and check this and if we do we can we'll
find that the Quran is false because it
doesn't say what uh what the Quran says
is there. So that's a that's a big issue
for me.
>> Exactly. And I totally understand your
point and uh with no offense I really
respect to be honest with you me you
know like my I have been taught in the
schools and you know like through my
daily life and through my parents that
you know even our religion and you know
because you read the Quran or you knew
some verses of Quran that Christians and
Jews mentioned as the people of the
book. Yeah. Yeah. So this is a
compliment like to to the Christians and
the Jews that they believe in you know
like in in books that revealed by God.
Yeah.
>> But there is there is a verse in Quran
and this is don't take it as offense.
>> You you could be as you could be as
honest and real as you uh as you want
here I won't take offense. I promise.
>> Yeah. So the verse saying that you know
that you know like the basically the
Quran has hasn't been you know like
corrupt or you know like you know
changed or
>> hasn't been it hasn't been changed.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So, so basically you
have the right as you read the Bible and
the Old Testament to say that you know
like uh Quran it was not mentioned in
them so the Quran is false but the
Muslims they will respond that oh our
book was not changed and has never been
you know like changed so maybe uh you
know like the Bible the one who has
changed or something so it's
from both. Yeah. Both ways they can
argue.
>> Yeah. The so the reason why that
argument wouldn't work is because
obviously the Quran points to the
previous scriptures as if you know
saying that they're true and like it it
it says in Sarah verse 47 it says let
the people of the gospel judge by what
Allah has revealed in it. And whoever
doesn't judge by what Allah has revealed
then those are among the rebellious and
wrongdoers. Right? So according to the
Quran, I have to judge by my gospel. Um
and and so it doesn't make sense to uh
think that Allah is telling me to judge
by a book that is changed and corrupted.
Like I don't think Allah would would
mislead me in that way to do that.
Right.
>> Yeah. Yeah. So my understanding to this
point of view uh basically you know why
why god didn't send one messenger yeah
or let's call it one person to uh with a
one book for the the for all the
humanity you know like for all the time
so basically my understanding to how the
things works back in the days yeah god
sent you know like different different
people or different prophets let's call
them. Yeah. To different people and at
different times. So every like Moses he
came with the Torah and Jesus came with
with the Bible. So uh every recent book
came to you know with the new new things
that the people they have to follow. So
basically what I'm trying to say the
Jews that believe in Moses at the time
when Moses was down on the earth they
will enter the paradise and they will
you know the their religion is totally
correct and the you know the Christians
who believe in you know like what Jesus
when Jesus was on the earth they will
enter the paradise but you have to
follow the let's call it updating from
the god that he sent a new messenger.
>> Yeah. But yeah, but but here's the issue
with with this is that when you guys are
are saying that that that God has
revealed these different messages, you
guys are coming and saying that the
previous messages are corrupt. They've
been changed. There's no way back to
them. And all we got is the Quran now.
And so that's the problem is that the
Quran never says that. It never points
to that. But in it says the opposite
that the Quran's mentioned in these
previous scriptures that we have to
judge by these previous scriptures that
we have nothing to stand on unless we
stand on the Torah and the Injil right
the gospel or or else we're losers. Um
to believe in the Quran because the
Quran confirms what we have with us. So
the Quran over and over again affirms
that the Bible is true and is preserved
and it's authoritative. But Muslims tell
us the opposite. So
to be honest, it it's a very good point
from you to mention that because in
Quran it's never mentioned that the uh
you know like the Bible and the Old
Testament has been you know like touched
or corrupted.
>> Exactly.
>> Yeah. But yeah, it's never mentioned. I,
you know, I read the whole Quran and
there is no a single verse that's saying
the Bible or Torah has been changed or
this
>> but uh yeah the Muslims they think this
because of
>> the contradiction and I don't know if
they are right or wrong. So they could
be right,
>> they could be wrong. But you know like
the this contradiction it's always there
like there is a contradiction between
Bible and Old Testament when old
testament no there is you know like old
testament in inosia
11:9 it says god cannot be a man
>> it doesn't say that it doesn't say that
at all and we can trust
>> you could you check it
>> we we can we we can do that in just a
second I I promise I have no problem
going over those uh those verses and
clearing that stuff up cuz it it doesn't
say that. Um, but my point is is is this
is that if let me say I granted you I
don't agree but let's say I granted you
that the Old Testament and and the New
Testament contradicted each other. Well
then that would just still there's still
a problem with the Quran because it's
affirming the Old Testament saying the
Old Testament is true and it's saying
the New Testament is true. But then if
the New Testament, Old Testament
contradict each other, then the Quran is
affirming two books that contradict,
saying that both is true. So that means
that the Quran is still has a problem.
It'll still be false for affirming two
books that contradict each other. You
get what I'm saying?
>> So
>> uh yes, I understand. But as I explained
it, as far as I know and my knowledge,
I'm still, you know, like seeking
knowledge. So basically as I said you
know that any recent religion came after
the the the one before it it came with
let's I I will call it it's like an
update or a new information that it
doesn't you know like exists in but that
new that new information cannot
contradict the previous information
right it just adds to it it contributes
to the old
>> yes right yes I agree with Yeah. So the
pro the problem is is that the Quran
comes and contradicts the old
information. It's not in line with it.
It doesn't add to it, but it goes
against it. And that's the issue we
have.
>> Okay. You so so please. So because this
is as well one thing that I I confused
when you know like I was searching uh so
in the Old Testament. uh H 119 that said
God cannot be a man and in the New
Testament you know of course that uh
they you know they believe that Jesus is
a god and you know some of them they
believe he's a son of god some of them
they believe he's a god
I'll clear this up I'll clear this up
with you really quick but then I I want
us to come back to this point here but
you know you've been dealing with this
honestly so I I have no problem Um,
definitely clearing this up for you. So,
let's go to Hosea. Hosea 11. All right.
>> 11:9.
>> Yep. Here it is. We're going to look at
it in this context and show you what it
says. Okay.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. All right. So, this is Hosea 11.
Okay. Now, we're going to just read a
few verses before verse 9. Okay. It
says, "How can I give you up, O Ephraim?
How can I hand you over, O Israel? How
can I make you like Adma? How can I
treat you like Zeboim?
My heart recoils within me. My
compassion grows warm and tender. I will
not execute my burning anger. I will not
again destroy Ephraim. For I am a go for
I am God and not a man, the holy one in
your midst. And I will not come in
wrath. So the context of this is God
having mercy on Israel instead of
completely destroying them because he
promised to preserve them. Right? So
when he says, "I will not execute my
burning anger. I will not again destroy
Ephraim." Because he promised he
wouldn't do that. For I am God and not a
man. Now he doesn't say I cannot become
a man. I cannot take on a human form. He
says, "For I am God and not a man in
light of him going against his promise."
Men go against their promises. They
break their word, but God doesn't. So,
it's talking about his character as one
who's consistent and one who doesn't go
against his word like like man does.
Does that make sense?
>> Yeah. Kind of. So because you explained
it uh you know like that in in this uh
type you know in exactly these two
verses that you know like it's the that
character who are you know like talking
or let's say
>> yes exactly
>> saying yeah not not not the man
character
>> exactly exactly
>> or
>> so so and we do have verses where it
does teach that God will take on a human
form so we So, so that was Hosea. If we
go to uh Isaiah and we go to Isaiah
chapter 9 verse 6, this actually tells
us that God is going to come in the form
of a boy.
All right? So in the form so he says for
to us a child is born to us a son is
given and the government shall be upon
his shoulder and his name shall be
called wonderful counselor
mighty God everlasting father prince of
peace. So this son to be born this child
who's being given is identified as the
mighty god and everlasting father and
the prince of peace. So God,
>> this is the this is the Old Testament.
>> Yes, sir. This is the Old Testament.
Prophet Isaiah.
>> So yeah, we we got we have some uh some
some verses like, you know, in the Old
Testament that demonstrates that yeah,
God in the future plans to come to us in
human form. And so when it happens, when
Jesus comes and reveals himself, we
shouldn't be surprised when he comes and
he says things like, "I'm the one who
gives eternal life." or I'm the
resurrection and the life or I'm going
to judge on judgment day and I'm going
to raise the dead and decide who goes to
heaven and hell. I'm the Lord that you
have to submit to um to get to heaven.
He says all are to honor the son the
same way they honor the father, right?
Like he has he deserves that same level
of honor. So
>> Jesus makes these crazy claims that a
mere human prophet cannot make or else
he'll be blaspheing committing shock you
know.
>> So
>> yeah thanks for the explanation and I
appreciate that you know you you
answered the question to to be honest I
don't need to take more time because
it's not fair for the other people. I
have a lot of you know like questions uh
regarding you know like the some
confused confusing points that I faced.
So I will you know like I will follow
you and maybe we can talk because you
know we need to give other people chance
to come up and speak.
>> Well
I follow you and hopefully I will uh I
will speak to you.
>> You're you're welcome anytime and I I
really enjoyed this conversation. So,
you're welcome anytime, brother.
>> Yeah. Thank you very much. Have a good
day, man.
>> You, too.
>> All right. Pretty good guest. Pretty
honest guest.